la poursuite de notre engagement au sel
ne se fera pas un cadre monstre nous
allons avec nos partenaires engagés à
nos côtés mais aussi avec les pays de la
région parce que j'ai toujours ce souci
les associés de travailler avec le tirer
des enseignements de ce qui a fonctionné
notamment les évolutions nous avions un
peu impulsif justement à pau aucun cas
bénins mais tire elle aussi les
enseignements synapates la présence
durable dans le cadre d'opérations
extérieures de la france ne peut pas se
substituer au retour de l'état et des
services de l'état à la stabilité
politique et au choix d'ailleurs nous ne
pouvons pas sécurisé des autres qui
retourne dans l'anomie parce que des
états décident de ne pas prendre de
responsabilité
c'est un peu cynique ou alors c'est un
travail sans fin c'est pourquoi à
l'issue de consultations nous conduirons
avec nos partenaires en particulier nos
partenaires américains jouent un rôle
essentiel
depuis le début et j'ai police les en
remercier et nos partenaires européens
sont aussi d'un côté on a un coût et
dans quel but n vous alors sur une
transformation profonde de notre
présence militaire au sahel
on est modalités et le calendrier seront
précisées dans les semaines à venir de
prêts d'ici à la fin du mois de juin je
vais finir
ce travail des métaux prochain cette
transformation se traduira par un
changement de modèle
il impliquera le passage à un nouveau
car c'est à dire la fin de l'opération
barkan en coopération extérieure pour
permettre une opération d'appui et de
soutien de coopération aux armées des
pays la région qui le souhaitent et de
la mise en oeuvre une opération
militaire et d'une alliance
internationale associant les états de la
région est plutôt d'un partenaire
strictement concentrer sur la lutte
contre le terrorisme
ce nouveau cadre préservera nos
engagements auprès de partenaires
engagés à nos côtés dans la force des
coups bas et dans l'opération de upm qui
devront poursuivre leur montée en
puissance